♪♪Wolf, Wolf, hunting far and
yonder♪♪
♪♪
Bill:
The forest is brimming with
wolves.
Bill:
It's my job to hunt them
down, not yours.
But we can hunt them together.
Wolves, bears, dragons even!
♪♪
Cartoon Saloon, they make these
profoundly human films.
Very beautiful, very poetic
films.
♪♪
Something's happened to me.
I'm a wolfwalker!
Yeah, it's flippin' great!
You have four legs now, you can
run really fast and jump so
high!
Simon McBurney:
And in this film the natural
world and the human world
Simon McBurney:
are interconnected always as
people become animals
Simon McBurney:
and animals become people.
♪♪
Ross Stewart:
Cromwellian Ireland is a
fascinating period in Irish history.
Ross Stewart:
Cromwell is like the baddest
villian in Irish history
if you ask most Irish people.
♪♪
Cromwell:
I want all the wolves gone from
this forest.
Bill:
Yes, my lord.
Goodefellow, you have two days.
Ross Stewart:
Funny enough, he's the hero to a
lot of English people.
Towns people:
Kill the wolf!
That's when we had the idea of
two kids, one from England and
one from Ireland.
I'm a wolfwalker, when I sleeps
I'm a wolf!
When I'm awake, I'm me: Mebh.
Mebh Óg MacTíre!
What's your name, anyway?
Robin.
♪♪
Our two main characters, Robin
and Mebh, actually seem very
different.
♪♪
Svend Bond:
Robin would be a lot more subtle
in her movements,
Svend Bond:
a little bit more dainty.
And Mebh is a little bit more
broad.
Shhh, do you hear that?
Robin muffled:
What?
(Mebh belches)
♪♪
Svend Bond:
The thing that made the
animation unique for this
Svend Bond:
production I felt was that there
was a lot of focus on making
Svend Bond:
things seem very natural and
keeping the lines more loose.
♪♪
Svend Bond:
So for us in rough animation we
could be a little more free.
Robin:
You can't stay in the forest,
they're cutting it all down.
No way, I scare them off!
(Mebh howling like a wolf)
♪♪
The style that we were aiming
for was extremely high.
♪♪
Helga Bjarnadóttir:
We developed a way of offsetting
the colors outside of the lines
Helga Bjarnadóttir:
to make it look like mistakes
and wood-block printing.
♪♪
Helga Bjarnadóttir:
The forest line was quite
difficult to color.
♪♪
Helga Bjarnadóttir:
We developed a style to kind of
make the outside of the color
Helga Bjarnadóttir:
shapes a bit fuzzy, to look
like watercolor.
♪♪
Helga Bjarnadóttir:
We had to do quite a lot by
hand, which took longer.
But in the end it looks
beautiful.
♪♪
In this film, there is this very
interesting relationship with
nature.
Simon McBurney:
In which flows into the human
world and back out again.
Mebh:
Why'd you want to be human?
Being a wolf is way better, I'll
show ya.
♪♪
Simon McBurney:
The amazing thing of working
with Cartoon Saloon,
other than the beautiful
animation and the stories...
Smell ya later, Townie.
...is the fact that something
touches us.
♪♪